4 minutes
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues avec cette
proposition de résolution contre les
violences pornographiques que nous
examinons aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement une priorité publique avec
le développement de l'Internet les
conduits pornographiques sont devenus
quasiment libres d'accès via un
ordinateur ou un téléphone or comme le
démontre le remarquable travail de nos
collègues de la délégation droit des
femmes ces contenus diffusent des images
souvent dégradantes reposant sur des
maltraitances des viols ou du
proxinitisme y compris de mineurs et on
assiste une banalisation la diffusion de
ce type de contenu pour le plus grand
bénéfice d'une industrie qui elle
prospère c'est pourquoi comme l'a dit
notre collègue Loïc Hervé le groupe de
l'Union centriste votera cette
proposition de résolution visant à
susciter une prise de conscience dans
notre pays pour améliorer le soutien aux
victimes renforcer la réponse pénale
contre ces violences empêcher la
diffusion de ses contenus illicites et
protéger notre jeunesse côté réponse
pénale nous disposons déjà d'un outil
exemplaire réuni en Europe la plateforme
Pharos regroupant policiers gend cette
plateforme effectue une veille
d'Internet et dispose des moyens
juridiques et techniques pour retirer
les contenus illicites ou en bloquer
l'accès sur la base de signalement tout
ceci sous le contrôle d'une personnalité
qualifiée Laurence peccot Rivollier
membre de l'arcom j'ai pu échanger avec
eux leur témoignage sont atterrants à la
limite du supportable lorsqu'il s'agit
d'enfants ou même de nourrissons leur
travail est exemplaire la création d'une
catégorie violence sexuelle serait
effectivement bienvenue mais les moyens
de farose doivent être alignés sur cette
ambition en particulier la personnalité
qualifiée dont le travail est très
éprouvant et qui mériterait d'être
remplacé par une structure collégiale
maintenant la régulation sur Internet
dépend aussi et principalement d'un
législation européenne le digital
services actes récemment voté prévoit
que les autorités des États membres
peuvent demander aux fournisseur d'agir
contre les contenus illicites je
regrette toutefois et je l'ai maintes
fois dit que la responsabilité des
fournisseurs de services d'hébergement
dont on connaît le modèle économique
particulièrement toxiques demeure
limitée dans la diffusion de ce type de
contenu n'oublions pas qu'ici même
Francisco gun la lanceur d'alerte nous
avertissez que facebook privilégiera
toujours le profit à la sécurité des
enfants ainsi dans la proposition de
résolution européenne sur la lutte
contre les abus sexuels sur les enfants
en ligne qui a été adoptés par notre
commission des affaires européennes le
15 février dernier avec mes collègues
Ludovic et André Ray Charles nous avons
redis cela et nous avons proposé aussi
que la Commission européenne puisse
indiquer au public quel fournisseur ne
respectent pas leurs obligations tout
cela dans une logique de nemen shame
afin que le risque réputationnel les
incite à respecter scrupuleusement la
réglementation ensuite merci aux auteurs
de la proposition pour leur mesure
visant à mieux protéger notre jeunesse
notamment la mise en place de
dispositifs de contrôle parental à
activer par défaut sur les appareils ou
l'écran noir qui seraient imposés au
site ne vérifie pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs ces recommandations
confortent celles que nous avons faites
avec mes cours à porteurs pour mieux
lutter contre la pédopornographie cette
Luna nécessite des efforts plus que
redoublés au niveau national comme au
niveau européen car elle constitue une
délinquance de masse multiforme qui
prolifère ainsi en 2021 l'agence
policière européenne Europole que j'ai
pu visiter il y a une quinzaine de jours
démantelez le réseau boystown qui
comptait 400 000 utilisateurs sur les
Dark web on peut aussi rappeler
l'enquête ouverte contre Tik Tok l'an
dernier pour son non signalement de
contenu pédopornographique l'Union
européenne détient hélas un triste
record mes chers collègues celui du
premier hébergeur de contenu à caractère
pédopornographique dans le monde et en
France selon Madame pecorivolier sur
150000 contenus litigieux examinés par
elle en 2021 environ 70% étaient des
contenus à caractère pédo pornographique
en majorité publiée et détenue par des
hommes tout âge toutes catégories
socio-professionnelles confondues voilà
pourquoi il y a urgence